House Republicans stepping up their
efforts to hold the administration
accountable for the chaos at our
Southern border a house committee
releasing two articles of impeachment
against Homeland Security secretary
Alejandro mayorcas over the weekend
speaker Mike Johnson says he intends to
hold a housewi vote as soon as possible
let's bring in Brandon Jud National
border of Patrol council president
Brandon it's good to see you here's what
Mark green the chairman of the house
Homeland Security committee said about
uh forwarding these articles of
impeachment he said having exhausted all
other options
to hold secretary mayorcas accountable
it is unmistakably clear that Congress
must exercise its constitutional Duty
and impeach him uh green uh Johnson
belied that they've got the votes to
pass this in the house they might even
be able to have a trial or or at least
put forward the articles of impeachment
and then pass a trial off to the Senate
where it will promptly die and mayorcas
won't get impeach the president won't
fire him so in your mind what's the
upshot of all of this is it worth it
I I do believe it's worth it and I I
absolutely believe that chairman green
is correct they do have the evidence on
their side to show that he is not
actually enforcing our laws and that is
what he is required to do and if he
doesn't enforce those laws he's
complicit with the cartels and allowing
everything that we're seeing on the
border to happen and for those reasons
he should be impeached now just because
he's not going to get convicted by the
Senate we know that it's it's politics
the Senate isn't going to convict him
because if they did that then the
Democrats in the Senate would be saying
that Joe Biden is also complicit in
everything that's happening so when we
look at the evidence and we break it
down they have no choice but to impeach
him get the impeachment let the Senate
not convict him and show that this is in
fact politics but we must push forward
because what we're doing right now is
not enforcing our laws we are allowing
the cartels to have control of our
border this came up at the White House
briefing on Friday here's what the press
secretary said in
response it is shameful that's how they
want to use their time uh
uh to uh you know wasteful time uh to to
try to impeach uh secretary my orcus I
think it is shameful and what they
should do to should do which is the
premise of your question is work with us
work with Democrats work with
Republicans you know work with the
Senators who are actually trying to do
something to find a solution first of
all is is it shameful in your mind what
the Republicans are doing and then
secondly this idea of working on a
solution a lot of people would say that
the White House has got all all of the
solution it needs right there in the
president's executive pan yeah so I'm so
sick and tired of hearing her rhetoric I
am sick and tired of her not having that
honest conversation with the American
people not giving him them all the facts
so that they can make informed decisions
it's not shameful what our government is
supposed to do is try to hold people
accountable that aren't doing their job
and it is clear that this Administration
is not doing what is necessary on the
border and going to that point I would
love to see legislation and I'm sure
that what lenford and and everybody is
working on is going to be beneficial to
the Border but let's be clear that we
don't have to have legislation this
Administration through executive action
could do what is necessary to secure the
Border today if they wanted to they just
don't want to because the political lmus
doesn't allow them to do it when we look
at the Arab Americans and them
potentially not showing up to vote well
if he were to secure the Border through
executive action then all of that base
of of support that wants open borders
they're not going to show up for
election so he's been between a rock and
a hard place he cannot do executive
action he wants Congress to do it
because then he can throw his hands in
the air until that open border Bas said
hey it wasn't me it was Congress that
did this hey Brandon we're out of time
so I need just a quick answer to this if
I could where do you come down on this
dispute between the state of Texas and
and the government over Shelby Park and
not allowing the border patrol in well
we're we're completely supportive of
governor governor Abbott what he's doing
has has been able to allow us to deploy
our resources to better locations all
right great Brandon J I was good to
catch up with you thanks for starting us
off this week on the border appreciate
it thank you I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley airheart and click
here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis